cheating
is a cardinal sin in esports and even
just being accused of it is enough to
seriously damage a pro player's career
these
are the stories of players who were
dragged down by
false cheating allegations but survived
and came back swinging these are the top
10
cheaters who were proven innocent
at number 10 we have the north american
prodigy himself
stewie2k he's going to get flashed in
he's going to just go for it
oh my god stewie accusations of stewie
cheating in cs go reached
boiling point in january 2017 when
youtuber dan
m released a video in which he claimed
to have damning
evidence of stewie2k using aimbots to
cheat
as you can see he's looking back the
tunnel and his crosshair locks on the
guy's head and follows him
and what can we say there i mean it
looks pretty [ __ ]
while the video gained a lot of
attention big names in the scene such as
mo
and summit were quick to come to
stewie's defense look at shroud play
24 7. shroud has the best cross
replacement i've ever seen
he literally is always on the guy's head
no matter what it is so this is just
crosshair placement when you play enough
you know
this lines up with the headshot level
the people that accuse all these
counter-strike players are cheating
in my opinion i think they say that like
they can have just hacks built into
their mouths
or i think this should know how any of
that [ __ ] works dude
stewie's former teammate freakazoid also
spoke out about his personal experience
with the smoke criminal
and why it just wasn't possible for him
to have been cheating
why would a cheater that was playing in
the same land house as all of us
leave his computer on at night so
in the open for all of us to see i've
been on stewie's computer
i just didn't see [ __ ] i don't even know
what you guys are
like a cheater just is more like
secretive about their [ __ ] this guy is
like
he doesn't bro since then the
accusations
have died down stewie2k has solidified
himself as one of the greatest north
american counter-strike players of all
time
and his reputation remained spotless
at number nine we have bolo showing us
how being
too good at the game can make life
pretty difficult
for anyone who's not up on their rainbow
six siege bolo sits as one of the game's
biggest stars in the attacking side
being sent out as well
although not spotting the yokai coming
closer and closer to jaws music
amplifies
but now in the hallway that's four for
polo will he get the ace turning the
corner
some of his plays are simply
unbelievable and for some
a little too unbelievable he just
randomly shot through the garage dude
literally he shot at one spot he
completely flicked to the other side of
the garage and shot and killed me
headshotted me right in the head
how are you able to snap to the same
spot like that
man despite the murmurs of cheating in
some
corners of the siege community no
serious allegations were
ever leveled against bolo he never took
the comments too seriously and
lucky for us he didn't shy away from
including them in his famous
meantash videos nope i don't even i
don't even care if he's just gonna go
use this in a meme video i'm gonna
report boilo
every single time i ever play him
every single time i play him
[Laughter]
sometimes players are faced with
multiple cheating accusations at once
like in the case of our number eight
entry ardis
you are facing off against an op but it
is flashed oh what oh
come on ice paper hands you can't you
don't already like that i know i used to
know your name but you can't be this
cold
before the accusations artists had made
a name for himself as one of the
best in valorem just before g2 picked
him up
accusations of cheating and match fixing
arose dating
back to his cs go days cheating
whistleblower it's gamer doc
release footage that seemed to show
artists discussing match fixing
in the uk cs go scene so like you'll
tell either
or whatever mal will tell his meets his
mitchell now one page now we don't even
tell we don't tell that
anymore yeah
mao was the one i didn't trust at all
artists refuted
all allegations he said that while
facing financial difficulties
he listened to a presentation from a
cheetah but never went further than that
the question was did riot believe this
behavior was behind him
i'd be surprised if ryan's not looking
into the scepter after that article
um and i don't think that we'll see
artists get signed until riot clears it
yeah
eventually ardis announced that a riot
investigation had found
no evidence of suspicious activity while
playing ballarant
these days he's sitting on top of the
valorem world with g2
at least when it comes to european
competition and now everyone knows he's
legit
look at jenny's head
and number seven is a streamer named
mika daimay who was accused of
hacking in valorant now her accusations
didn't stem from some
massive catalogue of suspicious footage
they came
from a single clip her accusers tried to
claim
this clip looked way too jumpy and the
crosshair seemed to
unnaturally skip take a look for
yourself
if you aren't convinced some big names
in the ballarat scene
certainly were pros such as wardell and
player 1 weighing in
only serve to fan the flames of
suspicion
she's acting she's hacking dude what the
look look look
she hits look look at the look how she
she throws the knife at the
silva and then it instantly goes up to
his head aimbot for some
that was all they needed to hear mika
was harassed on her stream as things
went from
bad to ugly even in my stream they just
go to my stream like
telling me that oh i should just kill
myself
or like it's such a shame that you know
that i cheat and then i have the face to
still stream my games eventually a riot
employee stepped in to
clearly state that after a thorough
investigation
they found that mika was innocent this
was followed by a similar joint
statement of innocence from her talent
agency
and riot games which seemed to finally
put an end
to the whole ugly ordeal some people or
some dreamers can't
take all the bullies and they hate you
know people are just mean in the
internet
so yeah i don't know it's just it makes
me sad
at number six we have coldzera this cs
go
legend has had frivolous aimbot
accusations
plague him throughout his career but one
of the most notable came in 2016
from the same guy who accused stewie2k
at the start of this video
dan m and then there's a point where his
crosshair picks up speed
and locks directly onto the opponent
through the wall
and then it holds it holds it holds
holds and then he goes to the door so
this is a clear example of him
getting information with his aimbot two
years later the accusations were still
following coldzera around and then he's
going to afterlock onto his first target
after he kills him and then accidentally
lock onto the second target over there
on the train
when he steps around the second and
third time to shoot at his target you'll
see his crosshair get tugged towards the
target just like a low fov aimbot would
do
these accusations have never gone beyond
murmurings though
and fans are quick to dismiss any new
ones that arise
let's remember he is considered to be
one of the greatest cs go players of
all time and now his skills are truly
unquestionable
popping noggins he's cleared three
bodies and the fourth
i didn't i didn't think it was actually
gonna
i didn't think he would actually do it
at number five we have guri the korean
overwatch sensation she was well known
for being one of the best
zarya players around in 2016 but as with
many of the other people on our list
her skill only seemed to raise suspicion
inside gaming
laid it all out by the way she did so
damn good at the tournament that a
number of opposing players
thought she was cheating because of
course they did hacks after defeating
one of the teams to proceed in the
qualifier she was officially reported to
blizzard korea for using
hacks it all came from the 2016 nexus
cup qualifiers
her team uw artisan convincingly beat
their opponent dizziness
but two of the losing teams members
claimed that gaguri was using an
aimbot specifically in this part of game
two
this quickly led to her being called out
on korean social media as
a cheater strobe one of the original
accusers
even allegedly said that if there was a
problem with his team's sponsors as a
result of the loss
and supposed cheating that he may visit
geguri's house with
a knife in hand eventually blizzard
announced they had found
nothing to indicate geguri had been
cheating if that wasn't enough for the
haters
she even did an hour-long stream with
her whole setup in frame
just to show that her skills were legit
coming at number four we have taimou he
was the captain of overwatch's most
dominant roster in summer 2016 envious
that made it all the more shocking when
clips started to emerge
online that claimed to show taimou was
aimbotting
came forward to say that when he signed
taimou to the team
he personally built him a computer with
his
own hands to make sure that he wasn't
cheating
after seeing him smash solo queue for a
few hours
they were convinced that the accusations
simply weren't true
in the end those accusations disappeared
and these days
taimou takes the whole experience as a
badge of
honor i never really care like i think
it's a
take it as a compliment of like being
called a cheater
i want to be a friend to everybody kind
of but then i realized at some point
that's a
way of thinking so i can't please
everybody but
i i like the way of changing perspective
like people respecting my play so i
enjoy that a lot
at number three we have a young american
counter-strike player named leaf who
became the target of
not only cheating accusations but death
threats
the damage done through the smoke
doesn't matter when the trades come
through all in favor of chaos but ben
finishes the job and leave
still holding strong with a third fourth
as well
chaos it all started back in june after
an online qualifier match for cs summit
between chaos esports club and
mibr chaos won the match but shortly
after
all hell broke loose on twitter i'll let
colin tell you exactly how
in this clip from our don't happy on the
incident after the match on monday
leaf tweets out 2-1 against mibr ggs to
them
we all had insane maps plus a little
joke about steel
the replies to that tweet come in hot
and heavy
a lot of them being angry accusations of
cheating from
mostly brazilian fans unfortunately the
flames were further fanned when
community figures like
fallen tarik and popular brazilian
streamer gowless
weighed in and speculated about leaf
possibly cheating
during the match but despite all the
vitriol and speculation
no credible accusations were ever made
and plenty of online detectives have
weighed in to debunk
claims that leaf was cheating like this
investigative video
by a youtuber named opsi we can see that
the game's engine is not
rendering where fur is right now it's
rendering library
it's rendering boiler it's rendering
some of the apartments but it is not
rendering where fur
is meaning that wall hacks or any
hacks could not detect fur through the
wall
at the number two spot we have the
brazilian godfather himself
it's fallen fallen gets the spray shot
anyway
what what is that for the
third time on this list i'm going to
mention dan
m fallen did not escape his slander
either
according to mr crisp clean lock himself
some of fallen's replays showed
unnaturally robotic movements
as soon as his cross hits the model it
goes in an l shape
uh horizontally first extremely fast
and then vertically extremely fast right
into his head these accusations were so
absurd
that only mo seemed to actually take
them seriously
and even he called [ __ ] the scout
shot i could show it here in the clip
but he slow-mo the stout shot
and it looked like it went like robotic
like boom boom to the middle
but then other people showed him that it
does it with everyone's demo no matter
what it is if you slow it down that much
it looks like that
yeah but since then the likes of youtube
reddit and the hl tv forums
seem to have smartened up and these days
you don't see
baseless accusations being flung at the
two two-time major champion
thank god for that and
finally a number one but definitely not
a cheater it's rops
rob stepped into some big shoes where
mousesports signed him as their
replacement for
nico in 2017. it didn't take long for
people to see why
he's got the same amount of time and
that's a brilliant shot there
he's making them look a little bit
foolish now the shots he's hitting
10 seconds remaining though still a lot
of pressure to get that bomb down
oh he okay he's gotta get it down now
he's gonna go for the kill oh he's done
as well five seconds
unfortunately his game-defying skill and
young age raised the usual suspicions
even
fellow pros like simple and jw implied
he might be cheating rob can you
can you stop playing like [ __ ] robs
please we need your cheats man
and for a teenage robs accusations like
these from
legends of the game he grew up idolizing
really took their toll
that's the time i first got to play
against all the pro players
everyone was scared to play against me i
used to watch your frag movies and now
you call me a cheetah how is that even
possible
but there were always those who had his
back and defended him until his name
finally began to clear i think it's just
one of those things bro he has an ocd
twitch
i don't think he cheats i don't think
they're right about that man you got to
watch all the other you have to watch
all his streams and see why he's looking
there
in the end rox was flown out to the face
it headquarters and played the game
in front of the admins there to prove he
was legit
once they were satisfied he could
finally move on with his life
and continue to dominate the scene he's
retrieved an m4
i don't think it's got any ammo left in
it so he's got to get this done with the
deagle and he does find the first man in
he's just checked and yeah see another
option might be all
the tapes drops what is good name is
that
all right guys i hope you enjoyed that
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
if you are new around here and also
let me know in the comment section what
kinds of videos you want to see next on
the channel
we do read them we do appreciate them so
make sure you do that and i'll see you
all in the next video
i was playing phasmaphobia the other
week right and you guys know this is
like a
sort of scary spooky horror game and a
hacker got into one of my rooms
uh like my lobby and basically just kept
spawning these like
giant purple neon bunnies that hacker
stole that experience from me like i
know it wasn't cheating but
kind of kind of kind of you know kind of
is like cheating don't hack don't cheat
it's not good
stay in school